et nous accueillons le troc terrien du
samedi 20 heures ce soir laura fontaine
bonsoir
alors laurent vous avez 23 ans vous avez
déjà 28 3 fois le concert le premier
c'était à l'âge de 4 ans et le dernier
c'était il ya un mois à peine
aujourd'hui vous êtes en rémission mais
pas encore guéri et vous voulez donner
de la force au malade
et vous nous raconterez notre histoire à
20 heures
laura fontaine robe bon soir vous êtes
né le 7 mai 1990 à saintes en charente
maritime vous grandissez à cognac ou
votre père et tonnelier et votre mère
assistante de vie à l'âge de 4 ans vous
tombez malade
vous avez de grosses douleurs dans le
bas ventre et les médecins croient à une
crise d'appendicite
mais l'échographie révèle rapidement une
tumeur de 10 cm sur un os vers la
direction l'hôpital des enfants à
bordeaux où vous encaissez un traitement
très lourd trois séances de chimio par
jour ceci étant vos souvenirs sont
plutôt joyeux
joyeux oui parce que elle n'était qu'une
enfant donc à 4 ans se rend pas
spécialement content de ce qui nous
arrive
je n'avais pas spécialement d'effets
secondaires dus à la chimiothérapie donc
je courais dans les couloirs de
l'hôpital avec la personne qui est percé
et donc maman courait derrière moi en
tant que père fils allait les goûters
d'anniversaire des fêtes de fin d'année
autour du sapin enfin tout ça est assez
sympathique alors vos parents font bonne
figure aussi faut le dire et quand il
pleure c'est une fois qu'ils ont quitté
l'hôpital j'ai pas le souvenir qu'ils
aient craqué devant moi mais quand vous
avez une pause dans votre traitement et
que vous retournez à l'école vous mettez
rien sur votre mettez pas de foulard
vous montrez chauffe
et puis vous dites la honte c'est un
sentiment d'adultes finalement je pense
moi c'est vrai hélas la chimio ne
détruit pas que vos cheveux mais aussi
elle provoque une baisse des défenses
immunitaires
ça va de la paix et jusqu'au
avoir plusieurs transfusions et puis au
bout de quelques mois vous êtes
opéraient les médecins vous retire cette
tumeur vous n'êtes pas guéri vous êtes
en rémission et il faudra attendre cinq
ans pour vous déclarez guérir vous
rentrez à la maison vous retrouver une
vie normale vous retrouvé vos cheveux et
puis surtout vous apercevez que bon
voilà c'est un mauvais moment à passer
mais vous avez gardé quand même votre
âme d'enfant oui ces jeux l'influent
moyens voulait pas dramatiser
voilà alors à 9 ans donc vous êtes
déclarée guérie là vous grandissez
normalement passionné par l'équitation
et vous êtes au collège une ado comme
les autres vous envoyer des sms à vos
copines vevo premiers flirts en fait une
adolescence
et là l'été de vos quinze ans à la
veille de votre entrée en troisième
nouvelles douleurs dans le bas ventre
est-ce que c'est l'appendicite non plus
on l'a retirée c'est une tumeur cette
fois sur l'utérus alors seul moment
voulaient pas prendre conscience de ce
qui vous arrive voilà oui je je réalise
pas spécialement tant que temps que j'ai
pas d'hospitalisation temps qu'il a
fallu trois semaines à peu près pour que
tout se mette en place pour que les
médecins décident du protocole adapté à
mon deuxième cancer donc je continuais
plus ou moins à faire - cris
d'adolescentes dans la suite et
l'hôpital des enfants à bordeaux la
chimio mais cette fois votre corps réagi
très violemment contrairement à la
première fois là ça a été beaucoup plus
dur beaucoup plus dire j'ai exactement
les mêmes protocoles de chimiothérapie
qu'à l'âge de 4 ans mais mon corps se
souvient se souvenait de monde mon passé
du coup le corps s'affaiblit deux fois
plus que la normale vous aidez nous
aidez le premier jour ne pouvez pas vous
alimenter toutes épuisées ce qui vous
oblige à être réalité pratiquement 24
heures sur 24 mois alité et puis donc
des des perfusions d'alimentation parce
qu'un possible d'alimenter le peu que
j'arrive je le garde pour moi donc c'est
une grosse perte de poids pendant
plusieurs mois gros problème vous avez
mal aux yeux pouvaient même pas regardé
un film a été dévoilée à ce point là oui
c'était vraiment en étant à égalité en
restant dans le noir prostré oui
d'ailleurs les défenses immunitaires
baisse encore vous êtes obligé d'être
dans une une chambre stérile j'étais en
chambre stérile parce que je suis une
autogreffe c'est à dire qu'on a pris on
m'a prélevé mes globules blancs parce
que cette signaux à les détruire
vraiment encore plus mes défenses
immunitaires
donc une fois que la chimio était passé
on ne remet tait cessé de l'obuts blanc
pour en espérant qu'ils se multiplient
davantage vous réalisez que votre
adolescence est foutue vous prenez
conscience de la mort à cause d'un petit
garçon qui est dans la chambre à côté de
vous en fait on est rentrés quasiment
plus ou moins en même temps en chambre
stérile donc les premiers jours allait
tenir un enfant de 3 ans dans une
chambre stérile dans une dans une bulle
c'est vraiment compliqué donc forcément
il se met à pleurer i il criait enfin et
plus à l'est
forcément je pense qu'il avait eu sa
dose de chimiothérapie lui aussi donc il
était affaibli on je l'entendais de
moins en mois et jusqu'au jour où on m'a
annoncé son décès
alors c'était peu quand il vous arrive
de sortir de l'hôpital vous mettez un
foulard sur la tête
et votre mère est très inquiète elle dit
que vous ressemblez à une rescapée des
camps de concentration
le vrai choc
c'est la bla sion de l'utérus évidemment
donc les règles difficile dans ces
conditions de devenir une femme est de
passer de l'enfance à l'âge adulte quoi
ça a été
vraiment comme un coup de poignard quand
j'ai appris ce que le chirurgien
comptait faire plus j'ai ressenti
vraiment plus de haine que quand j'ai
appris que j'avais un deuxième cancer
était vraiment là le monde s'écroulait
séquences autour de moi et puis un jour
en plein mois de juin est en train de
ruminer sur votre lit d'hôpital je n'ai
pas bien dormi vous êtes abdullah vous
voulez rentrer chez vous l'oncologue
entre dans la chambre il vous sourit et
oui c'est fini c'est fini je me sentais
enfin soulagé c'est pas le fait de
vraiment plus avoir de cancer mais le
fait qu'on me laisse tranquille que je
joue ça y est je n'aurai plus jamais
plus jamais de chimiothérapie alors là
l'été magique évidemment vous reprenez
goût à la vie et grâce à l'association à
chacun son everest
avec une dizaine d'enfants atteints du
cancer vous montez au sommet du mont
blanc mais notre but c'est de franchir
notre everest à nous nos propres selon
nos capacités
à 18 ans donc vous obtenez votre bafa
vous commencez à encadrer des enfants en
centre de loisirs pendant les vacances
scolaires à 21 ans vous décrochez votre
bac et là vous faites votre valise il
est temps pour vous de les découvrir le
vaste monde j'allais à londres vous
travaillez déjà comme jeune fille au
pair vous allez à new york san francisco
fin vous croquer la vie à pleines dents
je rattrape
le temps le temps perdu dans les habits
dans les hôpitaux en fait oui j'ai une
soif de vengeance
oui et en juin dernier donc en 2013 vous
rentrez en france pour un examen de
contrôle
nouvelles tumeurs dans le bas ventre oui
je passe un scanner de contrôle parce
que je suis toujours en rémission dû à
mon second cancer et là tout de suite on
voit encore une espèce de nasse de 17 cm
cette fois ci sur mon mauvais restants
et là je me dis mince quoi enfin peux
pas me laisser tranquille j'ai encore
plein de projets en tête et du cou et
j'étais là à me dire ça va mal je vais
encore prendre du retard dans un projet
oui
mais au fond de vous vous dites j'en ai
vaincu 2 je vais vaincre et bien le
troisième bah oui comme on dit jamais
deux sans trois j'attends qu'un
troisième il est arrivé je viens de
créer le troisième quoi comme j'ai
vaincu les deux points alors avant le
stoud le soir même vous prenez un avion
pour l'on vous accorder quatre jours
avant de retourner à bordeaux pour la 3è
chimio donc à 23 ans et cette fois c'est
plus du tout la même chanson à bordeaux
vous retrouver chez des adultes
chaque malade reste évidemment dans sa
chambre s'asseoir alors c'est
impressionnant le changement j'étais là
je veux revenir en pédiatrie je m'en
fiche de 23 ans mais parce que c'est
impressionnant les
la mentalité tout a changé un enfant à
qui soit chauve ou pas il est tellement
pleine de vie et couleurs que là les
adultes c'était chacun sa caresse dans
sa chambre mais ses limites on va
attendre la mort quand vous avez subi
ainsi séances de chimio mais après la 2e
notre organisme a déjà atteint ses
limites
vous avez perdu 19 kg et comme il ya
zéro traces de cancer vous décidé
d'arrêter j'étais là dire aux médecins
c'est faut vraiment arrêter la chimie au
regard des mois si c'est pas le cancer
qui va me tuer c'est c'est la
chimiothérapie là je ne rigole pas c'est
quoi or vous sortez
oui je sors aujourd'hui vous êtes ans en
rémission
certes en danger mais plus sous
traitement là je suis je suis plus entre
est sous traitement gym à la dernière
ligne au début le début novembre
alors que reste-t-il de votre féminité
blessé pendant votre adolescence les
stocks sont en train de repousser je
voudrais garder une certaine longueur
pour assumer pleinement la féminité et
puis
j'ai de la chance que
je n'ai pas encore été touchées par le
cancer du sein c'est quand même c'est
génial pour moi je le reconnais donc oui
alors vous voulez lancer un appel laura
au don du sang c'est important faut
savoir que si vous voulez vraiment nous
aider ça serait bien d'aller donner
votre sang parce que la chimiothérapie
détruit tout ce qui est mauvais dans
notre corps donc la tumeur le cancer
nous détruit également tout ce qui est
bon donc sa patte de la perte aux
cheveux et donc le sens les globules
blancs et plaquettes ces globules rouges
donc oui allez c'est vraiment important
allait donner votre sang si vous voulez
vous sentir utile
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais 1
pouces bleus